In high school, the days tend to blend together
after a while. Math test, unrequited love,
annoying group project, stress, rinse, repeat.
Sometimes a big football game or a school dance,
or maybe a fight in the hallway
breaks up the monotony a bit,
but it’s normally pretty uneventful.
That’s always been fine by me. I’ve
never tried to be a popular kid or the center
of attention, I prefer to keep my head down,
work stage crew for the school plays, and just
hang out with the same small group of friends
I’ve known since we were little kids.
It was on one of these ordinary days,
in a long line of similarly ordinary days, that
something came to destroy the peaceful high school
existence I’d gotten used to. As I sat in history
class, passing notes with my best friend Zach
and ignoring a video about the Civil War, I
had no idea that I was about to live through
the worst day of my life. And I would be one of
the lucky ones; I’d survive. The others…let’s
just say they wouldn’t be so lucky.
I was just scribbling a response to Zach,
something about hanging out and playing
Xbox after school, when the PA system
crackled to life. Our principal’s voice
cut through the droning narration about
the Battle of Antietam as he spoke.
“Staff, this is a lockdown. Initiate
your lockdown procedures immediately. If you
are a visitor outside the building, please
leave the property immediately, and call 911.”
I assumed it was just another lockdown drill,
until I saw my teacher’s face. She looked pale,
her expression tight, like she was trying to hold
it together for our benefit. I could see her hands
shaking as she reached to turn off the video,
and when I heard the tremor in her voice I knew
for sure: she was terrified. This was not a drill.
As our teacher locked the door and we all
climbed under our desks to crouch in the
dark and wait out the lockdown, I could hear
my classmates whispering feverishly. Everyone
was trying to figure out what was going on.
Someone suggested a kid had brought a knife
to school. Someone wondered aloud if a threat
had been called in to the principal’s office.
Zach cracked a dumb joke about a mutated frog
escaping from the biology lab, when suddenly
a scream rang out, echoing down the hall.
Have you ever felt an entire room of people
holding their breath at once? I have.
We listened for the sound of fighting,
for gunshots, anything
...Nothing. And then another scream,
louder, closer, and longer than the last.
It was a scream of pure, unadulterated fear
and pain that dissolved into a wet gurgle that
made my stomach turn. Zach and I shared a look,
one that said, “whatever is going on,
it’s like nothing we’ve ever seen before.”
I could feel my chest tightening, and it was
getting harder to breathe. I tucked my head
between my knees, holding onto the back of my head
and trying to take in deep gulps of air. The room
felt as if it tilted on its side and I thought
I might pass out, when another sound brought me
back to earth. It was coming from the back wall
of the classroom, by the chalkboard. The sound of
liquid sloshing onto the floor, mixed with plaster
splintering apart and pieces clattering all over.
I tried to get a better look, but the
room was dark and I didn’t want to leave
the relative safety of my desk. If there was
someone, or something, coming into the room…I
didn’t want it to see me.
Zach had a better angle than me,
I could see him craning his neck to get
a better look, when he clapped a hand
over his mouth in shock. I heard him scream,
muffled, against his hand. What had he seen?
What was it? Before I could even ask, my teacher’s
cry ripped through the darkness and the silence.
“Get out! Get out!” She repeated over and over
again, and I could hear the raw desperation in
her voice. It was like someone ushering passengers
off of the sinking Titanic, someone who knows
there is no hope for them but hopes they can at
least save the children before it all goes down.
“Run! For the love of God just run!” Her voice
broke, from fear, from pain, or both, and the
sound was enough to get my legs working again. My
classmates had the same response, and we blindly
rushed for the door, flipping over desks and
knocking chairs to the side as we scrambled for an
exit. Zach grabbed my arm, and I held on tight,
afraid I would lose him in the chaos. Someone
unlocked the door and we poured out into the hall.
Just as I made it out of the door, I couldn’t
help but turn back and look. Call it morbid
curiosity, call it instinct, call it stupidity,
but I had to see what had happened. I turned
just in time to see a nightmare brought to life.
The wall was melting, covered in something thick,
black, and putrid. The smell invaded my nostrils
and I gagged on it. A wretched, grey arm had
its fingers wrapped around the teacher’s wrist,
skin peeling off to reveal muscle and bone.
It looked like it belonged to a corpse,
but it gripped her with inhuman strength. She
was pulling with all her might, but I watched
helplessly as the arm pulled her into the melted
wall like she weighed nothing, swallowing her body
and her screams with it. And then she was gone.
Zach tugged on my arm, hard, yanking
me into the hall.
“Come on man, run!”
He hadn’t seen what I’d seen, or
he would have realized that running
might not be enough. Whatever this thing
was, it didn’t play by any rules I knew.
Running was all we had right now, though,
so we ran. I looked around for a weapon,
something, anything I could use to defend myself,
but I couldn’t see anything that would help.
Instead, all I saw was the destruction the
intruder had left in its wake. All around me,
the halls I walked through every day were falling
to pieces. They weren’t just damaged. They were
coming apart at the seams. Lockers were warped
beyond recognition, walls completely dissolved,
sections of the floor reduced to
sizzling puddles of goo, and everywhere,
everything was covered in that same black slime.
It smelled worse than you can ever imagine. It
smelled like the complete loss of hope, like
the point of no return. It smelled like death.
We reached the end of the hall when I heard
something shifting behind us. I suddenly became
aware that we were alone. The sounds of frantic
footsteps, hushed whispers, doors slamming shut
and locking, had all quieted. Where was everyone?
I glanced over my shoulder, and saw one lone
figure shambling down the hall toward us. It was
far away, and I could scarcely make it out in the
darkness, but I could hear dripping, sizzling,
and the smell of decay grew stronger. That was
not a classmate or a teacher. Whatever it was, it
was taking people away, or killing them, I didn’t
know exactly what. But whatever it was doing
to everyone, Zach and I were next on its list.
The scariest part was how slowly it moved. Maybe
its legs were too rotten to move any faster,
joints disintegrating into useless mush,
but it seemed more deliberate than that.
To me, in my panic-clouded mind, it
seemed that it was taking its time.
It didn’t need to rush, it knew that, when it
wanted to catch its prey, it would. I couldn’t
suppress the sick feeling in my stomach this
time, I keeled over and vomited onto the floor.
When I looked up, Zach was beckoning to me
from just inside the doors to the auditorium.
“Come on! In here!”
He could have left me
behind for the intruder to take, tried to save
himself, and sacrifice the slow friend frozen in
place with terror, but here he was looking out
for me again. Even in this horrible situation,
I felt a surge of gratitude. I booked it
across the floor, forgetting for a moment
about the shuffling corpse making its way toward
us, and joined my best friend in the auditorium.
It was eerie in the dark, the curtain
soaking up and dampening sounds,
barely any light illuminating the normally
cheerful props and backdrops left from the
recent production of Alice in Wonderland. A once
friendly place felt twisted, like a mockery of
Wonderland with a monster stalking outside
and waiting to pounce. We sat on the stage,
listening to the sound of our labored breathing.
The air felt heavy, but I welcomed the smell of
paint and dust over the nauseating stench
that permeated the rest of the school.
“Are we the only ones left?” Zach
whispered, breaking the silence.
He was the first one to say what we
were both thinking, what we both feared.
“No.” I said with false confidence. “I think
some of them got out, before…” I couldn’t
finish the sentence. “Somebody had to get out.
It can’t just be us.” I leaned my head against
a giant papier-mache toadstool, glad it was too
dark for Zach to see the tears filling my eyes.
“What was that thing?” He asked.
“Did you see it?” I sat up straighter.
I thought I was the only one who’d gotten
a look at the thing, however fleeting.
“No. But I heard it. And…smelled it.” He coughed.
It took me a while to answer his question.
Eventually, I found the word. “It’s evil.”
We sat in silence for a long while after that.
I don’t know exactly how long. Moments like that,
where at any second you could be lost forever,
time stretches out into something unrecognizable.
I was starting to think, foolishly, that we might
be in the clear, when I heard a strange sound.
It was a creaking, like footsteps on an old
wooden floor. I looked around for the source
of the noise, but I couldn’t see anything.
It sounded close, impossibly close.
Creak. Creak. One step then another.
Where was that coming from? There was no
wood floor in the hall, nothing above us.
By the time I understood, it was too late.
The top of a head, slimy, clammy and grey,
with tufts of limp white hair clinging to
the soft flesh began to emerge from the
stage where we sat. Eyes, hollow and dead,
but somehow alert and searching for us,
came next, followed by a gaping wound where
a nose should be, and a wide, toothless grin.
It looked almost like a person, but it was wrong.
Just wrong. Every cell in my body rejected it,
screaming at me with thousands of years of animal
instinct that I had to run. I grabbed Zach’s
arm and yanked, but he didn’t come with me.
I turned to look, and my heart jumped into my
throat. It had him. Its bony fingers had a hold
on his legs, and he was already halfway gone,
pulled into a slick black puddle in the stage.
His face was damp with tears, as the reality
of his fate set in. He grabbed my hand in his,
and squeezed. “Run.” Was all he could get out,
before the old man pulled him out of sight.
So I obeyed my best friend’s wish. I ran,
and I hid in the prop closet, hand over
my mouth to stifle my breathing. Suddenly,
there was a loud bang, and I heard voices
yelling. Something that sounded like a gunshot.
A blast of bright light. Then, a voice, male
and official-sounding, called out: “Is anyone in
here? You can come out, we’re with the police.”
I opened the closet door and peered out, to see
people in hazmat suits wielding bizarre weapons
and carrying devices I’d never seen before.
The man who had spoken approached me, took
my hand, and asked me if I’d seen anything.
I got the strong sense that I should definitely
not tell him what I’d seen. “No, sir,” I said.
He nodded. Whether he believed me or not,
he knew I wouldn’t say anything more.
“Gas leak.” He said. “It destroyed
large parts of the building. Highly
dangerous. We need to get you out of here.”
They took me home and I hugged my parents
tighter than I ever had before. That night,
the news covered the tragedy at my school.
The “gas leak” had taken dozens of lives
before the authorities had gotten there.
Everyone else can accept that story all they want.
I know the truth. I see it when I close my eyes,
imagine it standing over me when I wake up
in the dead of night. Those hollow eyes,
that horrible smile, the stench of death and rot.
It looked right at me. It saw me. It wanted…I
can’t let myself think about what it wanted.
I don’t know exactly what I saw, but I know
a few things for certain: There was no gas
leak. Zach and the rest of the people it took
are gone. And, if that monster ever
escapes…it’s coming after me next.
Now go check out “SCP-106 - The Old
Man Escape” and “SCP-106 - The Old
Man Origin Theories” for more explorations
into the nightmare factory that is SCP-106!